SPEAKER 1: So
we're going to talk
about Cloud-Native Computing.
What's Cloud-Native Computing?
It's all of these words.
Let's highlight some of the
ones that are most interesting.
So Cloud-Native Computing
is an approach to computing
that prioritizes things
like containerization,
immutable infrastructure,
declarative APIs,
loose coupling.
And this allows you
to have principles
like observability, automation,
and really good predictability.
These are the
characteristics that
are embedded in
modern infrastructure
and are particularly
exemplified by Kubernetes.
Who here has heard
of Kubernetes?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Good.
Thanks for being awake for at
least part of the last couple
days.
All right.
So modern infrastructure
has been about the evolution
from treating servers like pets
to treating them like cattle.
And that's the benefit of
using a cloud infrastructure
like Google Compute Engine.
But cattle are still solid,
substantial, long-lived things.
You can say, look at
that cow over there,
that one by the fence.
You know, that one with the
sarcastic look in her eyes.
But with the next
wave of computing,
things like infrastructure,
you can't really
grab hold of servers
like cattle are.
The nodes, the containers, the
addresses, the pods, they all
blink in and out of existence.
And they're really only
comprehensible as a collective.
It's less like cattle, and
it's more like a big frothing
mass of microorganisms.
But you know what you get
from a big frothy mass
of microorganisms?
Beer.
So modern
infrastructure is great.
But it's very different
from the traditional ways
of doing computing.
So now, let's take a look at
how we've been doing CI/CD.
Here are some of the
models that describe
a typical CI/CD systems.
So first, we have the
Rube Goldberg machine.
You push a button here, and
that schedules a job there,
and that opens a
socket over there.
And that sends an
XML message over
to that thing, which writes
generated code onto a floppy.
And you give it to
the intern, and she
runs it across the street
and puts it in the mainframe,
catapults it up onto prod.
And you know what?
It works.
But these things are kind of
like a Heisenberg property.
If you peel back and try
and look at it, oh, no.
Never mind.
Walking away.
So it's very fragile.
Here is, of course,
the Frankenstein model.
It's been cobbled together.
And it's one of a kind.
Beautiful, really, in its way.
And this guy, he's going to
lurch and lumber, slow perhaps,
but steady to get your
stuff from source to prod.
And everyone once in a while,
one of his arms will fall off,
but if you know where to
find Dr. Frankenstein,
you can call him up and he'll
stitch that arm back on.
And of course, the
model of the hairball.
So we use these terms to
describe our CI/CD systems,
and we use them
affectionately, because we
crafted them and we
know all their quirks.
But let's face it,
these systems are pets.
In fact, this is exactly
what my cat looks like.
When I talk to customers about
the setups they're doing,
I often hear things like
we have one big server
and only Susan is
allowed to touch it.
Or we upgraded our
system, and now we
can run two simultaneous tests.
Or we have one
staging environment,
and the DBAs are
always messing it up.
This approach, it has worked,
sort of, for a long time.
But now that we moved to a
new kind of infrastructure,
we need to change
how we do CI/CD.
We need Cloud-Native CI/CD.
So right now, we
as an industry are
at the beginning
of a major effort
to establish a
new kind of CI/CD.
This is an effort to
modernize software delivery
to take advantage of all the
benefits of cloud computing
so that we can get
things like speed,
scalability, portability,
and improved quality.
Last month, the Linux Foundation
announced the Continuous
Delivery Foundation, or CDF.
This is a sister project to
the Cloud-Native Computing
Foundation.
The goal of the CDF is to
evangelize CI/CD, define
best practices, and
support collaboration
between practitioners
and vendors.
These are the premier
members of the CDF,
and they include,
as you can see,
big tech companies,
CI/CD veterans,
and some customers who are
active and proactive in CI/CD
like Netflix.
There's also a lot
of vendors that
are part of the
general member space,
and a lot of well-known CI/CD
tools are in that space.
So a lot of the industry
is coming together here
to define a next generation.
So the CDF's approach is
heavily informed by Kubernetes.
Kubernetes has
unlocked a new level
of runtime security and
portability and scalability.
So with the CDF, we're
bringing those things to CI/CD.
And we're embedding
best practices
so that we get containerization,
immutable infrastructure,
declarative APIs, all
that good modern stuff.
The initial projects in the
CDF are Jenkins, Jenkins X,
Spinnaker, and Tekton.
CDF fosters communication
between these projects
so that we get interoperability,
and we establish
shared best practices.
Let's take a closer look
at Jenkins X. Jenkins X
bundles together several
best-of-breed open source
technologies, things like
Jenkins, Helm, Skaffold, Prow.
These are all really
cool open source projects
that do specific things.
Jenkins X puts
them together into
a pre-wired
batteries-included solution
based on modern best practices.
And it provides an on
ramp to Cloud Native CI/CD
while maintaining
a lot of that user
experience you're familiar
with from Jenkins.
So let's see it in action.
Carlos?
CARLOS SANCHEZ: OK.
So I have here running
an application.
You can see I have--
this is a very interesting
game, which is shooting lasers
to crocodiles, right?
I could be playing this forever.
It's a lot of fun.
And I have it running here
in the staging environment.
And I have the
same application--
let's refresh it--
in production.
And you can see
here at the bottom
the version and the
region and the commit
that is being used to
build these applications.
So this is 134 in production.
I have 134 also in staging.
So let's say, what is my
typical development workflow.
I have my product in
GitHub, and I want
to implement the change, right?
It seems that shooting
lasers to crocodiles
is not very
environmentally-friendly.
So instead, we're
going to make a change
to make this more
politically correct.
So I could do this
some from my machine.
I'm going to just
edit the file here.
And Edit This File.
I'm going to make
a small change.
Game 2.
And I'm going to say no lasers.
And no, I want to
create a pull request.
And this would to go through my
typical process of code review
that we're going to skip
today, because I know
this is going to work for sure.
[LAUGHTER]
So what's going to happen
is, as you see here,
I have a bot that has
commented in my pull request.
It is basically telling me this
pull request is not approved.
This is a bot that is
included in Jenkins X.
And I can talk to this bot.
And I can say things, very
important things, like meow.
And my bot is going
to answer back to me.
So I can do--
I can talk to this bot.
There are several commands.
This is using Prow.
This is a project
from Kubernetes itself
that they use for
CI/CD of Kubernetes.
So this is basically
listening to web hook events
and doing things.
You can write your own plugins.
And you can see here, there
is a serverless Jenkins--
and I'm going to talk a
little bit about that soon--
and type checks that
are still running.
So if I go to my Command
Line and I think this is--
I want to check the logs.
Wait.
No.
OK.
So I can see the logs of the
build of this pull request
happening in Kubernetes.
So this is used in
serverless Jenkins, which
is a project that we
created that allows you
to have several lists built.
So every time there's a web hook
event coming into Jenkins X,
it will create a new
path for Jenkins.
So it's a small Jenkins server
running that it doesn't--
it only takes a few
seconds to start.
So it's not the whole thing.
You don't need the UI.
You don't need all
the extra things.
And what is going to happen,
it's going to create the path,
run that, and at the end of the
build it's going to disappear.
So you have two options on
Jenkins X. You have the option
to have a static master like the
typical Jenkins that you know.
And you have the
serverless option.
And this is going to be using--
pretty soon we're
integrating Tekton.
If you heard about
Tekton the project,
it was talked about
in other sessions.
It's coming from Knative build.
And it's basically allowing
you to use containers in your
build pipeline.
So let me get back to here.
This is still pending.
We can take a look at the why.
OK.
Get bots.
This is still initing
for some reason.
We can check the logs.
OK.
The path is still off course.
Maybe my cluster
is held to scaling.
OK.
Wait.
No.
Not that one, that one.
What may be happening
is that my-- this
has triggered my
cluster total scale.
So-- oh.
Init error.
OK.
So my build did fail.
I can see this in the logs here.
And it's not a valid--
oh, connection timeout.
Oh, that's not great.
So something happened here.
So maybe you can see
that it's a real demo
because it has failed.
[LAUGHTER]
I can-- I think
I can rerun this.
And I can tell to run it again
for some connection issue.
But in the meantime, I
can continue talking.
OK.
This is calling-- running again.
You can see here the logs
from your Jenkins pipeline.
So this will be the
same thing that you've
see on traditional Jenkins
in your console output.
So if we go to the previous
one, what it's doing
is-- this a Golang application.
So it's building the
Golang application.
It used it's Skaffold to
create the Docker image.
You can see here the logs
for the Docker image, build,
and then it's pushing the Docker
image to a private repository
before deploying
it to Kubernetes.
And it's also creating
the Helm Chart
and deploying the Helm Chart,
because everything in Jenkins X
runs a Helm Chart.
And it helps you--
specifically if you have
Kubernetes applications,
it helps you have a
really standardized stack
and pipeline for Helm
Charts and Kubernetes apps.
So this is running make now.
While this is
running, I'll show you
what's running
behind the scenes.
So this is running
in a cluster in GKE.
I have two clusters running.
OK.
This is two machines right now.
I have it done out to scale.
So it's here somewhere.
No.
Not that one.
Auto-scaling is on.
So what happens is with the
combination of these serverless
Jenkins on auto-scaling on
GKE, the more jobs I have,
the more builds I have, the
cluster is going to expand.
But it's also going to contract
when there's no jobs running.
So I get this elasticity,
kind of [? pay us ?] per use
that you would want
to scalable CI/CD.
OK, so this is the running.
Before I can escape, kind of
the question that I always ask--
raise your hand if you're
using Jenkins, please?
Yes, so a lot of people.
Who is using Kubernetes?
A lot of people.
Who is using Jenkins
or Kubernetes?
Just some people.
OK.
So this is a step forward.
The other way you can run--
you can run traditional Jenkins
with Kubernetes
grading agents on pods.
That's the plugin I
started a few years ago.
And this is going in the next
step, which is basically you.
Jenkins serverless,
you don't even
need to run the Jenkins
master all the time.
So if this works for you--
And this isn't working.
I think this is failing
in the same step.
OK, so this is--
OK, so let's switch
to another cluster
I have and we can see
if that works there.
There's some
connection going on.
So I'm going to
do the same thing.
I'm going to edit this.
I'm going to create
the pull request.
No lasers.
So this is another project that
I have in a different cluster,
because demos.
This should trigger
the same thing
if this doesn't work here.
Oh, no, it fails that.
OK.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
repository cannot be reached.
Oh, Jenkins stacks.io is down.
Wow, I didn't expect that.
OK, well, that's going
to be hard to fix now.
[CHUCKLING]
All right, so let
me talk through this
and hopefully things
will fix themselves.
So the other thing, because
I'm running this in GKE,
I can get all the logs
from my GKE containers
on my Stackdriver.
So I can filter for them.
I can see-- the same things
I can see in the console
or I could see in
the Jenkins output,
you can see them in Stackdriver.
So you can see that
the same error is here.
So this is very cool,
because then you
have this permanent storage,
and you can use Stackdriver
to just query, to
use for the APIs,
build applications
on top of that,
and do any sorts of
integration you want.
And we have created
also a cloud-based IUI.
So you can go and see what's
running on the staging
and production environments
in Jenkins X. Jenkins X,
by default, creates namespaces
for different environments.
So you get the staging,
you get production,
and the interesting
thing is that you
get one pull request environment
for each pull request.
So if I go to a
previous pull request--
pull requests here.
Let's go to one
that is closed here.
Whoops, no.
So when my build succeeds, what
it's telling me is basically
your pull request is available
in this preview environment.
So this is a namespace
on Kubernetes,
and it doesn't interfere
with my staging or production
environments.
So I could click here.
The link doesn't
work now because this
was delivered before.
But this would send me to my
application, my Helm chart
deploy, into a
preview environment,
a separate Kubernetes namespace.
So I can see my pull
request in action
before merging it into master.
And this is running, and this
is not going to work today.
All right, let's trigger
it again and see.
Close this and this.
OK.
Yeah, so if the test fails,
I get the details also.
My bot is-- it's
all ChatOps where
your bot is talking to you
and you can do these commands.
So I was talking about
environments, staging
and production.
So if I run jx get--
let me just cube off here.
And if I do jx get environment,
I see that I have staging,
I have production, and I have
two other assigned GitHub
repositories for each of them.
So if I go to a staging,
what I can see here
is my environment has a YAML
file where it's basically
saying what
applications do I have
deployed into this environment.
So this is GetOps.
It's my environment match
what is start in Git.
And whenever I want to make
a change to my environment,
I change it in Git,
and that triggers
the change in the cluster.
So if my cluster
disappears and I
lose all the data of what
applications I have deployed
or anything, I could
always come here and say,
this is the source of
truth for my cluster,
and I can reinstall
everything based on this file.
So I don't have to--
you don't touch your cluster.
Everything is going through Git.
And Git triggers the
build on the pipeline,
and that ends in the cluster
state with the applications
that you want.
So for the staging repository,
what Jenkins X does
is that automatically
upgrades your application
to the latest in master.
So when I merge my
pull request, it's
going to trigger a build
and create a new Helm chart
version.
And Jenkins X is going
to come here and say,
in the staging environment,
update the version.
So all these pull requests are
auto-generated by Jenkins X.
So it will say promote
Croc Hunter to version 134.
And this will go automatically
through the build.
And this is a very simple pull
request that Jenkins X does,
which is saying change
the version 133 to 134.
So this is done automatically.
Staging is always matching what
you have in your master branch.
The other thing I have, I
have the same equivalent thing
for a production environment.
So if I had run--
let me see-- if I
promote an application,
it's going to come here,
and because it's production,
I have to manually promote
it using a command.
And it will come here, make an
update to the Git repository,
and trigger the pipeline.
So if this doesn't work, I'm
going to skip through this
and show you the promotion.
So this is still failing
because this site is down.
So let's do something else.
I can get the applications I
have running in my cluster--
jx get applications.
So I have 0.0.134 in both
staging and production.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to promote an older version
that is already built.
This is probably
going to be here.
I'm going to promote 133, and
let's see what's in there.
So I can do jx promote
Croc Hunter Jenkins
X. That's this version,
0.0.133, dash dash, environment
production.
And what this is
going to do, it's
going to create that
pull request where
it goes to production and
says, instead of 134, put 133.
And while this is running, let
me show you something else.
I'm going to leave this running
here to not miss the logs.
OK, so this is doing--
OK, it created the pull request.
So this is a pull request
against my production
environment.
As you can see, this
is done automatically
after I did the jx promote.
The file changes--
instead of 134,
go to deploy 133 in production.
And this is run in the build.
The build has succeeded.
It was merged.
And now it's going
to be deployed
to production environment.
So I can see the logs of
the build and all that.
Now, until recently,
what this was doing
was just updating
the application,
so you immediately get
the version you promote
into production environment.
One thing I've
been working on is
to do a progressive delivery,
kind of redeployment.
So progressive delivery
encompasses canary deployments,
blue-green deployments,
things like that.
So basically you don't
want to deploy new versions
to all your users.
Because you don't know if
it's going to break something.
You want to deploy it
to a subset of users.
So this is the typical stuff
that Netflix, Facebook, Google
does.
So what we're doing, and what
I have enabled in this project,
is exactly that kind
of redeployment.
So I have-- basically,
Jenkins X has
the concept of applications,
Jenkins X applications
or extension points.
And one of them is Flagger.
So Flagger is a
project that will
do this kind of
redeployments for you.
And this is using Istio
and Prometheus metrics.
So what we're going
to see here is
that Flagger detects there's
a new change, a change
to my deployment in Kubernetes.
And instead of switching
the whole traffic to it,
it's going to create
the Istio deployment
configuration necessary to shift
traffic a little at a time.
So what we're going to do--
I have it configured.
It's going to do--
every minute is
going to shift 10%
of the traffic, so
10%, 20%, 30%, 40%, and 50%.
And then at 50 it's going
to deploy to everybody else.
So we're going to see that
in the logs in a second.
I also have-- it comes with
a Grafana dashboard here.
I have to forward the port.
There it is.
Where I can see the incoming--
the new version, the system
version, the new version,
the canary.
I can see the CPU request.
The CPU use says the
requests that are incoming.
And I'm going to
generate some traffic.
So you get some noise here.
This is basically
hitting the application,
printing the return
code, and what version.
And you can see that some
of them are returning 133,
and some of them
are returning 134.
So it's already
splitting the traffic.
And in the logs, I
see here, advance
jx production weight 10.
So that means 10% of the
traffic is going to the canary.
So I have 134 deployed.
The canary, I'm doing it
the reverse, so it's 133.
So if I refresh, I'm
getting 134, 133,
depending on this balancing
that Istio is doing.
And I should get some
traffic now here--
yeah.
So the primary is the
previous version, canary
is the version I'm deploying.
So I can see the success
rate, all sorts of metrics
that you can have.
All these metrics, you don't
have to touch your application
to do anything.
Really, this is automatically
done with Istio.
So Istio is basically
proxying all the requests
to this application
automatically.
It's sending the
metrics to Prometheus.
So you get status codes,
you get response time.
Those are the two metrics
I'm checking here.
But you could see
lots more metrics,
and you could create
your own metrics.
But for these, you don't need to
touch your application at all.
So what's going to happen also--
this is advancing,
it's 20%, it's 30%--
before this rolls
out completely,
if I do it quickly
enough, I will show you
how we can automatically detect
that the new version is having
issues and how this is going to
roll it back without you having
to do anything.
So let me open--
and I'll explain
this in a second.
What I'm going to do--
my application, I have
a couple of special URLs
that are going to return
500 errors and delays.
So I'm going to force
errors into my application
to see how Jenkins X is
going to handle those--
Flagger is going to
handle those and roll back
my application automatically.
So I need to hit this URL.
I'm going to run this.
I need to run this from
inside the cluster.
And what I'm doing here
is creating a DevPod.
Jenkins X has this idea of
DevPods, which are basically
containers--
Kubernetes pods that have
a stack pre-installed.
So you can choose--
I chose a Golang DevPod.
So it's creating a pod and
giving me a shell into it.
So I can run whatever
development environment
commands that I want.
I'll show you in a second.
I just need to make it fail
before it finishes deploying
or I have to start it
again, which is too late.
OK.
It's too late.
So it went up to 50%.
This is good.
I'll show you the whole thing.
Once is succeeding,
one is failing.
So it went to 50%, and
basically now all the traffic
is going to the version
I have promoted.
And let's see the kerl.
You see all the requests are
getting version 133, which
was the one that was deploying.
And if I go here to
my Istio gateway,
yeah, I'm getting version 133.
On the version 133, because
I couldn't make the change,
this is not the one
I wanted to show.
But just see that
the release is 133,
and it's a different commit.
While in the
staging, I have 134.
The staging hasn't changed.
Some I'm going to do
the promotion again.
I'm going to say, OK,
I want to promote.
jx get applications, jx
promote, dash dash production.
So I'm going to
promote 134 instead
of 133, environment production.
OK, so this is going to
do the same thing again,
but changing the version.
All right, so it has
created the pull request.
Same thing--
GitHub's repository.
And this is going
to be automatically
tested and deployed.
There it is.
And in a second,
this will be up.
So I was here.
My DevPod was created, so I
can start injecting errors.
So this is not just for errors--
oh, let me show you again.
I think-- and this.
So I'm creating
the DevPod again.
So you see I have
different stacks.
I have Go, I have
Maven, I have Node.js.
And this is reusing
the one I created.
The other feature it has,
it has the synchronization.
So this should work.
So this is automatically
copying my local contents
to the remote pod.
So if I go--
I'm running out
of consoles here.
It's this one-- yes.
And I touch a file
in my local machine.
I can go to the remote machine
and my test file is here.
So this allows you
to edit your files,
work on your
development machine,
change files, do whatever
you want, use your IV,
and this gets automatically
synced to Kubernetes.
And in the remote
machine, what I can do--
I can do make, I can
do a Docker build,
I can do a Helm chart
build if I want,
with the benefit that is
this is all running remotely.
So this is running on Google.
It's using Google
internet connection,
which is going to be a lot
faster than uploading Docker
images from my development
machine to a Kubernetes cluster
and then doing it.
So this helps you,
using the cloud
to do the things that are
heavier for your developing
environment.
OK, so let's try this again.
OK so Flagger has now detected
there's a new revision.
So it's starting again
the canary process.
And in a second, it's going
to shift 10% of the traffic.
And we can see it here.
You can see that after
the canary deployment
before, the canary version
is not getting any traffic.
That's a scale-down,
and all the traffic
is shifted to the-- the canary
is moving to production,
and all the traffic is
shifted to the new version.
And the canary is stopped.
So it's all on
demand, based on when
the canary process happens.
OK, so I'm getting 10% of
the traffic now to my canary,
and this is starting to pick up.
This should be
starting in a second.
There is some-- getting some
traffic on the new version.
What I'm going to do
is force the failure.
And you see some of them are
getting 134, most of them
are getting 133.
And I'm going to
force some here, yes--
I'm going to force errors.
Some I'm going to
force my application
to return 500 errors, and
let's see what happens.
So this is going to start
showing that the success
rate is dropping.
And Flagger is going
to detect that and do
the rollback automatically.
So the success rate
is falling, and I
think I have it configured.
I'm going to show you the
configuration, because this
is going to take a little bit.
So this is a YAML file that I
did include in my Helm chart.
I'm saying canary is enabled.
These are the hosts
that I used for Istio.
And this is the canary analysis,
which is the important piece.
So step weight is the 10%.
I'm increasing up to 50%,
that's the steps I want.
I'm saying, do it
every 60 seconds.
And threshold is how many
times can the metrics
fail before I do the rollback.
So if the metrics fail three
times, do the rollback.
And the metrics that
I'm using is two metrics
that are sent by Istio.
I don't have to do
anything in my application.
So I'm saying, every 60 seconds,
check the request success rate
and make sure it's over 99%.
And make sure that the seconds,
the duration of the request,
is under 500 milliseconds.
So check these two metrics, and
if they fail, do the rollback.
That's what I have configured.
And this one as well.
And you can see here--
can you see it in the back?
What's happening here
is how the advancement--
because the success rate is
93%, which is less than the 99%
that I had set in
my configuration.
And the second time is-- oh, now
it's 49%, which it still fails.
And the third time is now 44%.
So this should automatically
roll it back in a second,
because it has noticed
that the new version,
the canary version, is failing.
And I can go back to Grafana.
The success rate is going
really, really down.
I can also get these logs.
Again, the Flagger logs, you
can get them in Stackdriver.
OK, so there it is, the halt--
halt the production deployment.
So you can get all
this information here.
And in a second or more--
OK, the sooner I say it,
the sooner it happens.
So production, fail checks,
threshold reached 3.
And canary failed.
Scaling down my canary
deployment in production.
If I go to my kerl, I
see that now everything
is returning 133.
So it's all rolled
back, and my canary
should stop getting
traffic now because it
has been rolled back.
So it's going back to
the previous version.
So I think-- well,
if you want to take
a look at the application,
that's the GitHub repo.
And you can see how the
Helm charts are configured.
One thing I didn't mention--
I'm just going to show it now--
other things that you
can do with Jenkins X.
You can do jx
create quick start.
It's a very easy way
to start creating
Kubernetes applications.
So I'm going to
create demo next.
And I can choose from one
of the existing templates.
So I can create an Android
application, a Golang, a Node
HTTP, a SpringBoard.
So let's create a
SpringBoard application--
yes, yes.
So this has created
the scaffolding for me.
Let's go to my GitHub repo.
So you see it has my--
it has a Docker file,
it has a Jenkins file,
it has my Helm
charts, Helm charts
created for my specific
type of application.
And I have the deployment
for Kubernetes, the service,
everything is
already configured.
So this is a very nice
way to start with creating
applications on Jenkins X.
[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]